دارت الطيران الفيدرالي الامريكي تقول
بانها تسعى للسيطره على عطل فني في نظام
الاشعارات الجويه اثرى بل اثر على عمليه
الطيران في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اداره طيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه قالت
ايضا ان الطلاعات في كل انحاء البلاد
تاثرت بالاعطال في النظام وانهم يعملون
على استعاداتها وكلاست رويترز للانباء
اشارات ايضا الى ان مطاراتي باريس الدوليه
تتوقع تاخيرا في رحلاتها على خلفيه
الاعطال في انظمه حواسيب الطيران
الامريكيه
وما زلنا اذا نتابع عبر هذه
تقول طلبنا من شركات الطيران ايقاف كل
الرحلات الداخليه حتى الساعه 9:00 صباحا
في التوقيت المحلي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الان هي الساعه همم السابعه و25
دقيقه صباحا بتوقيت الساحل في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه شركه يونايتد الامريكيه
تقول نظام الطيران الفيدرالي ارسل اشعارات
بوجود مخاطر وقيود على الطيران في الوقت
الحالي
من ارضيه احداث او واحد من المطارات
الامريكيه صور مباشره لعدد من الطائرات
الرابطه في ارضيه المطار ربما توقفت جل
هذه الرحلات نتيجه هذه الاعطال في نظام
الاشعارات الجويه
ستتاثر اذا حركه الطيران الامريكيه همم
التاثير الطالع ايضا مطارات باريس
وكاله رويترز للانباء
بان الرحلات تاخرت على خلفيه هذه الاعطال
في انظمه حواسيب الطيران
الامريكيه
لدينا مزيد من المتابعه مع مراسلتنا من
واشنطن حسن ابو بويك بيسان ما اخر ما اعلن
بخصوص هذه الاعطال وتاثيرها على حركه
الطيران
نعم اخر المعلومات هي اعلان اداره الطيران
المدني انها ما زالت تعمل على استعاده
اجهزه الاخطار هذه الاجهزه التي همم تخطر
الطيارين وربان الطياره
وترقامها باي معلومات حول العمليات على
الارض او اي اخطار محرقه لذا هناك عطل
طبعا فني في اجهزتها وما زالت تعمل على
استعاده هذه الاجهزه وانها امرت جميع
شركات الطيران
بوقف الرحلات الداخليه
حتى الساعه 9:00 صباحا بعد ساعه ونصف من
الان حتى يتم التاكد من صحه وسلامه
المعلومات طبعا كان هناك ايضا مع همم
اعلان ايضا من اداره طيران المدنيه قبل
ذلك قول ان بعض همم بعض الامور باتت تعود
الى العمل ولكن يبدو انها همم وظائف بسيطه
جدا وانا الامر لم يحل حتى الان وزير
النقل الامريكي بيت بوتاجاز قال في تغريده
بانه على تواصل مع اداره وهيئه الطيران
المدنيه حول هذا العطل الذي يؤثر على
الاجهزه ويوفر المعلومات معلومات السلامه
والامن للتواقم التيارات وانا تعمل على
حلها بشكل سريع وامن لاستعاده العمليات
طبعا